what do I think about sharks tank I got
a question from one of my loyal youtube
viewers Arturo who wrote in asking my
opinion on sharks tank he said just out
of curiosity Ivan what is your opinion
about the show shark tank have you ever
seen it in my personal opinion I don't
really like flash deals other people
might think it's a good idea because
flash negotiations might give you an
unknown advantage I think this also
applies for the other party's advantage
okay so let me back up for a second here
in general I love sharks tank it's one
of my favorite shows I've watched almost
all of the episodes and I believe that
there's not enough quality programming
especially on TV for entrepreneurs if
you want to learn about being a great
entrepreneur and also be entertained in
the process there aren't a lot of great
chose to do it and so sharks tank is a
pioneer the show actually started in
Britain is called Dragon's Den then it
came to Canada dragons damn and then it
came to the u.s. sharks tank and two of
the founding members of shark tank were
the best two people from the canadian
show Dragons Den so it's kind of been
fun to watch the history but before
sharks tank what was there for
entrepreneurs nothing there are no great
shows on for entrepreneurs there may be
some shows you know like Pawn Stars
which I which I love where it highlights
a business and how they go through their
day-to-day life of running their
business and West Coast custom is
another great one and you learn a little
bit of it but there's nothing like this
like sharks Hank is a educational tool
as well as being really entertaining to
watch I'm a big fan now in terms of the
flash deals here's what you have to
understand about sharks tank okay first
of all the negotiations don't happen
that quickly as somebody's coming in the
pitch and it's actual discussion
understand that those discussions are
not just the three minutes that you see
in a shark's tank it's it's like half an
hour to an hour long for each person is
coming in it was a terrible idea then
they get kicked out early but when
there's actually a deal it doesn't
happen in three minutes like you see on
the show it's edited down massively the
other thing to think about is a lot of
the deals that are done
on the show don't actually end up
happening you know when you see the
update later on from what happened last
year it's not of every single
entrepreneur because a lot of the deals
do fall down in due diligence so due
diligence is is is what it's called when
investors looking into a deal if they
like it or not if they're going to
actually put their money so they shake
hands on the show but then they still
have to do due diligence afterwards and
a lot of deals fall apart on the table
you know if you don't like that deal
either as the entrepreneur or as the
shark a lot of deals don't end up
happening also think about when you're
coming on the show a lot of
entrepreneurs have in their head a
number that they're thinking about
they're not just being blindsided right
there not just they know what they're
getting into they're coming on the pitch
for an investor to come on and take a
piece of their company so it's not like
they're coming into something totally
foreign or someone's just calling them
out out of the blue and said hey I want
to buy half your company and so at the
end of the day everybody agrees on a
deal I don't think they're being taken
advantage of I think again because of
that process afterwards where everybody
still has to agree after the show's over
and they still have to sign the check
and sign the document that the no
transfer the shares over whatever the
agreement is that it gives still some
time for people to decide both from the
entrepreneurs and for the shark
sometimes the sharks will drop out
because they don't like to deal anymore
but overall I love the show I'm a huge
fan i watch I've watched I think almost
every episode anybody who's out there
supporting entrepreneurs educating
entrepreneurs showing that if you have
an idea you can make your business
happen I think that's quality
programming needs to be more of I'd
support more sharks tanks in different
countries or more related episodes my
other show that I like watching now is
called the Prophet it's on CNBC not as
popular and think just in season two but
a show but an investor coming in and
making businesses better and I think we
need to see more of those programs if
you guys like a show let me know I'm
going to check it out there's a great
fictional show called how to make it in
america that I think was on HBO and has
been canceled so you can look it up and
find it online how to make an America
awesome show but
me know what you guys think I want to
hear what shows you like if you liked
this video you can give it a thumbs up
leave in the comments the shows that you
think are must watch for entrepreneurs
and and i'll check it out i'm really
curious to see what you have to say so
thank you guys and you can subscribe to
the channel if you want to see more
videos i will see you soon